hello everyone i'm alana and i'm joined
by andy from kind of funny and to more
from gamespot slash giant book
yeah
everywhere everywhere i've already been
speaking about elden ring
for the last 15 minutes but off the
record no spoilers but i wanted to get
these two together to chat about it
because we've been playing it for almost
a week
um my first question is just gonna be uh
what what are your thoughts my friends
what do you think top level
it's very good isn't it it's very good
isn't it
it's very good i don't know why anyone's
surprised because you know from software
have they made a bad game yet
no dark souls 2 oh
no no no no no
no i agree that dark souls 2 isn't the
best but
a bad dark souls game is still better
than 99 of most other games is what i'm
saying clearly unbiased
yeah appreciate it
not that i decided
um
is pretty great that's true
universal uh tam what's your like
you have a synopsis if i if you were i
was stranger on the street i'm like tell
me about elden ring well what's your
what's your general synopsis of your
experience with your you said 40 hours
you played 60. 60. 60 hours uh my
overall experience is i think this is
one of the best games ever made
um i think that it's a fascinating and
refreshing change from the games that we
have today
in that genre i think that most modern
open world action games are bloated over
designed
um a bit of a mess um deeply
anxiety inducing um i love open world
games but when i open a map these days
even something that i'm really enjoying
like horizon when i see all the markers
and all this nonsense it just makes me
feel like
i can look at it and be like i don't
care about that that that that that that
that that there's a list of [ __ ] i need
yeah yeah and i and like and by that it
just makes me disengage in a completely
like
automatic way where i just start to lose
interest in it
um i think this is the polar opposite of
that where it's like we're gonna tell
you nothing and you're going to figure
out yourself you're absolutely right it
doesn't it doesn't do the open world
fatigue problem of giving you a
checklist of like here's a million
things you need to look at the only
things that i'm finding like that on the
map are
if there's a symbol that i'm like i
wonder what this is and then i go to it
and that's entirely my own discovery
it's not me trying to take a box and and
that's what you get out of it by telling
you nothing when you discover something
it's still meaningful to you even if
that thing isn't particularly
interesting or isn't particularly
rewarding because it trains you very
quickly
to appreciate exploration and the act of
discovering something it was your choice
yeah it's your choice you did it and
the way you do like the way i think of
it is like you're a cartographer in the
lands between like
the map is purposefully very bland and
when you go to a location it fails it in
you you get a map fragment and it will
fill that area in and then even that
area the points of interest are still
not marked you need to go there and
physically see them yourself and
interact with them and it's like i said
where that thing might not be all that
interesting it probably won't progress
the story or move you closer towards
your ultimate objective
but you have the satisfaction of knowing
that hey i found this in this world this
is the thing that i discovered and if
you're playing with a bunch of people
you can check with others the amount of
times that like i found something and
sent a message to andy and he's been
like i don't know what that is or andy's
found something and sent it to me i've
been like what the hell is this
conversation yeah exactly exactly and
that's that's like the magic of this
game it's like
is i described it in my review as the a
master class in design by reduction and
it's i think it's like phenomenal
because of that
yeah i was uh i was worried
that i feel like they are very good at
level design i feel like from soft is
very good at level design and i was like
it's gonna lose some of the magic i'm
worried that it's not gonna be as good
if they can't pace where i turn around a
corner and there's a giant snake looking
at me if they can't choose when i do
that
some of the magic might be gone the
reality is the absolute opposite that
i'm choosing where i'm going i'm coming
across something and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this and also i love that i
don't know
if a certain area is too high level for
me or not until i get there and then i
have to make the decision based on
approaching something rather than seeing
a health bar that's like this is your
level 50. you can't kill this i run up
and i'm like oh god i can't do this the
the discovery is super super super
exciting and i'm very glad that i was
wrong um about worrying that their level
design is like such a big
part of what makes their games good
because yeah it's like it's the wonder
of exploring something without being
shackled to anything at all
and i i love that people are finding uh
different things andy you having a
similar experience with the open world
yeah when it comes to characters telling
me where to go i i agree with tam that
i don't fully agree with tam in that i
do enjoy some games that have
some direction i think goes to sushima
um did a phenomenal job in terms of like
being a modern open world game but
having
me having reasons to care to go see what
the hell was actually happening there um
and i think a lot of that just comes
down to are you vibing with the story
are you vibing with the characters in
horizon i was not vibing with a lot of
the characters so i just didn't care a
whole lot on on those aspects but
it's gameplay what i was hoping it would
be i figured
what does a from software game look like
with an open world formula how do they
scale that up
they're going to have
all of those cool easter egg
mystery type moments that you discover
or you hear about from somebody or you
see online you're like i have to see
that for myself wait there's an npc
standing over there oh that thing only
comes out at night time
all of those conditional moments that
only happen if this and this happens if
you if you enter this area and you are a
part of this people like all of the [ __ ]
that i love about from soft games that i
think take them into like a higher
echelon of game developers
it's that on a massive open world scale
and it's a [ __ ] big world this is
huge many of them there are so many of
those things like the breath of the wild
comparisons are unavoidable i feel like
that's going to like cover the discourse
for the next absolutely month until the
end of time i think breath of the wild
is one of the best games i've made i
absolutely love it but in comparison
eldon ring has so much in it like even
if it's just i turn a corner and there's
a new enemy type that i don't know what
it's gonna do and i'm like oh is this
thing poisoning me oh cool it is like
and it's just figuring out like there's
a dude on the top of a cliff who just
fired this fire bolt at me like there's
it's so much stuff all the time i don't
even know how it runs to be clear though
probably one of my sole criticisms is
i've had so many frame rate drops
thousand percent yeah the uh i just
downloaded the day one patch a little
while ago i'm hoping that alleviates
some issues that was that was one thing
i had to make mention as well in our in
the games cast we did
and that uh i had a decent amount of
frame rate drops nothing that would in
any way make me put the game away or i
didn't have any frame rate drops in
moments that were like during a boss
fight where it was constantly happening
and ruining my
my experience it was just like running
across an open world and i turned too
fast and suddenly things are stuttering
to load in possibly i would agree it's
not enough that i care but it's very
frequent like it happens all the time
but not in a way that i was like yeah
damn you video game i was just like oh
frames i
i don't know if it's i don't know if
i've just got lucky but i never expected
like i've maybe like a handful of times
had it where it's happened and it's
exactly when andy said what only says
like where i spun the camera a bit too
quickly and it's like just catching up
but otherwise like it's not super
frequent for me at all like i wanted a
30 80.
i got a 30 90 damn you 30 90. 3080ti
yeah but i mean that is like i said one
of my my only criticisms uh in general
the other one is something that we were
talking about kind of earlier was that
um the navigation i feel like is
sometimes unclear and it's not like you
want it to be perfectly clear the
exploration is one of the best things
about it i [ __ ] love going into a
down a little staircase and it's pitch
black and then it turns out that there
are 10 bug men attacking me and i have
to figure out why and then a chest
teleports me somewhere and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i love that that's exciting but
sometimes i feel like things are
pointing slightly in the wrong direction
um
the sights of grace will point you
towards in theory where you are supposed
to head towards um
and i had a thing that i would consider
to be like bug
like
where
i had gone east around something that it
clearly wanted me to go north around and
because i went east
uh the sites of grace just kept pointing
north even when i had passed the thing
so they should have been pointing me
west or south at a certain point but
they kept pointing me north until i
went back to uh a more southern one and
then it was pointing me in the right
direction because i just went to the
east
unless it changed my priority or
something
i feel like that's a kind of a thing
that i was like sometimes i don't know
where exactly you want me to go in a way
that's not like i care about where i
need to go because there are so many
cool things to look at it just feels
like the system is
at odds with itself occasionally
um those are probably the only two
things i i found to have any issue with
yeah i i don't disagree um i
for some for whatever reason with the
way that i was playing
the sights of grace telling me to go
places i kind of just stopped listening
to yeah because i immediately kind of
felt like they had different things in
mind for me to go do
as opposed to progressing the main story
and plus a lot of it more was me talking
to npcs back at the your little hub area
and somebody would mention
go here and here and i know and i've
been there before and i was like i need
to get into there i'm not sure how yet
how am i going to figure out this
mystery and that's where sort of a lot
of the exploration uh began along with
just texting tam back and forth where
did oh you found that there oh really
that's awesome hell yeah let's keep on
sort of progressing this together and
that may not work out if you don't have
people to text and stuff like that but
it was i was
i was laughing
i was laughing about it uh on the review
because i was like yeah tim was like
andy you're our main reviewer what's the
score you're giving and i was like hell
of a game for you to pick to be my first
official review with all this [ __ ] cause
like
i've played through uh different souls
games with twitch chat and everybody's
telling me what where to go and what to
do and i'm getting my handheld and i
love it because i'm loving the
experience and this was
a very opposite experience yeah where
we're just going in
we don't know what a lot of these items
do we don't know
that oh you're not supposed to give that
item to that person even though that
they accept it you should give it to
this person and wait like yeah there are
so many of those dark souls from
software moments that are embedded in a
lot of the game design language that we
just don't know the right answers to yet
and i'm excited to find out what the
hell those answers are i'm excited to
see all the videos that come out oh by
the way this person they may tell you to
do that you shouldn't you should go like
all that [ __ ] i'm so excited about yeah
you're right it is uh
it's kind of an exciting time to get to
play it um and then we're figuring it
out as we go and we don't know what
certain [ __ ] means and that's really
cool but there was one thing that i was
like god i wish i knew where to find
this yeah yeah i've had i've had loads
yesterday i spent legitimately 15
minutes weighing up wherever i should
attack an npc because i couldn't figure
out what to do i was like
if i hit you will this fix or will this
progress i don't know what's going on i
went when you sent me a photo i went to
that spot and i had the same bus should
i the lady yeah yeah
i wanted to hit it i did that with a
dude on the beach where i was like oh
yeah yeah maybe he just chilling
not sure if he just killed him i did
andy did you figure that lady out no i
don't i still don't know
four people and they're like i have no
idea what to do with that lady wow
[ __ ] tell me something new andy can't
figure out a lady
yeah but i think that's like an exciting
thing about it it doesn't feel overly
obtuse to me or anything like i
i how long have you played andy
close to 70 hours i think like 68. you
guys have played way more than i have
yeah you're playing
six hours
right now yeah and the thing is i that i
think people need to understand is a lot
of the reports coming out before this
are saying you could be the game in
30-ish
and i very much think we could beat the
game at 30ish uh tama's mentioning on
our podcast that it very much has the
you guess it breath of the wild approach
where you can go kill gannon really
quick if you want um and
i had reached that point i was like oh
[ __ ] this is end game i don't want this
to be in game
there's still a lot and
i thought that i knew how much left
there was and there was way more than i
thought there was and i've had
that i think the thing that excites me
the most is that
a lot of these areas that we go visit
and explore and kind of dungeon crawl
through
i thought okay
you have to kill the two people to go
advance the story and we'll see what
happens when we get there
but i've killed the two people
there are other people i'm aware of that
i can go kill
and surely those experiences will be a
watered-down diet version of what we
just experienced because those are the
main people the other ones are probably
going to be similar or probably going to
be smaller dungeons and stuff no they
are not they are still
really well thought out and
incredibly designed and
presented and
those big dungeon areas are where you're
kind of getting that from soft feel in
terms of level design in terms of
walking down a corridor and
some [ __ ] is going to stab you on the
left side like all of that [ __ ] is kind
of what you would expect from a fromsoft
game and that's what that's i'm really
happy about that that it is an
interesting balance of open world and
linear in that way yes yes absolutely i
was super worried about that because
like playing when i played dark souls 1
for the first time i was like this is
this is some mountain rushmore [ __ ]
greatest of all time level design i've
ever seen in my life and i was worried
we were going to
not get a whole lot of that uh and
happy to report that i think that that
there's still a lot of those moments in
this game
level like oh it's it's good level
design in an open world like the fact
that i'm i'm like so excited to talk to
people about it and i'm excited for
everyone else to get to play it i'm just
like i can't wait for you to experience
this and
like watch twitch streams of a game that
i didn't work on and have people be like
whoa what like all this stuff that
they'll find is so cool yeah i think the
one thing that i don't want this to
sound like i'm pulling for my review
here i think the one thing that um
distinguishes it from other games in in
this org and by other games i mean
specifically breath of the wild is the
feeling of
authorship behind everything where um
breath of the wild you think about it
and it's an impressive game it's
fantastic but there's a kind of
disconnect between the open world and
the key areas of uh gameplay opportunity
like the shrines right you're always
running
between yeah you go to a shrine
you step on the left hard cut you're
inside this new shrine it looks like all
the other shrines but the puzzle is
different and then you complete that and
then you leave
so that's a majority of the things
whereas and and
the fact that they can share assets and
kind of have a
a reusable design template through each
of those
it's both beneficial to making a game
like that but
it's also detrimental to creating a
world that feels alive and
real and
it works within the context of breath of
the wild because you know those shrines
are those shrines they're put there by
you know different
peoples and that kind of stuff the thing
about the this game is so impressive is
like you have nothing feels
generated if you know what i mean it
feels handcrafted it feels
like a person has
thought this through it's not it's not
an algorithm or any or like it's not
like copy paste copy paste change this
to here and there it genuinely feels
like each one is unique and that that is
like and and the thing that's on top of
it that's impressive impressive is
there's a cohesion to it all there's
never a break in you going from one
thing to another except when it's from
a a big set piece moment you know
overall to a big set piece moment in my
in my review i describe it as the breaks
happen when you're going um from
somewhere like helmet john or lane to
cainhurst castle and but that's exactly
what you're getting out of it you're
getting when it breaks you're getting an
impressive
from software level out of it yeah but
even when you you're not overworld when
it's not doing that you're still getting
an impressive from software level out of
it albeit a smaller one which is one of
the most impressive things about it and
it's also like aesthetically varied it's
not like you get the same like in zelda
blue and gray
light it kind of counts the amount of
enemy types there are yeah like i just
kept finding new ones and not knowing
what they did all the time like i can't
believe how many there are and that's
why i'm so forgiving of when i do see
a copied version somewhere else because
i know that it's it's it's rare and um
and usually when you do see it it has
some sort of
um iteration of it maybe this one does
fire instead of lightning or this one
has three heads instead of two like
there's always going to be something
kind of different and unique about it
and that i look i look forward to
finding caves and catacombs
and tunnels and
ruins because i know that there's going
to be something cool there whether it's
a boss fight that you're really going to
dig or whether it's the loot that
they're going to drop or just getting a
lot of runes to level up like those are
all
super enticing for me to where i don't
i don't want to miss uh a [ __ ] square
foot of this whole world and it's it's
huge but i would feel like i'm doing it
a disservice to not continue to explore
and i'm genuinely enjoying all of it
yeah that is
that is what i've done now like uh
i've now gone to the self of the map and
i am
literally going from point to point just
anything that looks like it could be a
point of interest on the map like just
meticulously going through it and the
reason i'm doing that is because like
andy and i talked about this elsewhere
like um
we reached the point where we just
accepted that we weren't going to
complete it and
and we weren't going to make the embargo
and it was like a genuine weight was
lifted off of our shoulders definitely
for me i'm sure for andy as well i was
like
i don't think i can complete this game
it's like impossible i think rushing you
would also hurt your review yeah and it
genuinely has one of the i like i
haven't mentioned like one of the this
is the worst way to experience a game
i've been so excited about like my my
excitement for this game is known
and the fact that like um i like at the
same time as being like very thankful
that i've been able to play and do the
job that i do
it's been so depressing doing it in this
way because like there's there's been
days where i have to keep on playing and
my eyes are literally burning i've got a
headache my back hurts because you're
trying to get through something like you
don't even know how long it is and yeah
i it's that's an interesting one because
when the value of the game
feels to me so much like it is in the
open world and then occasionally going
to fight a boss and not consistently
doing that
if you were to just try to rush through
all of the bosses you would be playing
an entirely different game like just do
all the credits to everybody else and
the thing on top is like it's a game
that's
uh kind of
patience is critical to it so if you
take a beating
and lose your call like you're gonna
make that thing way harder on yourself
and it's really hard to not get
caught in a vicious cycle when you are
losing and then knowing that you're also
losing time that you need to yeah
make progress towards hitting a deadline
you could have leveled up by now i could
have leveled up by now if i can just be
if i i can't beat this boss i'm wasting
three four five hours on this boss and
that is an interesting thing to to weigh
up that i've been having is
do i want to try to beat this thing that
i think i'm pretty close to beating
or am i not the right level like i said
earlier like i don't know what level a
certain part of the world wants me to be
in it doesn't tell you that so i'm like
wait should i try this or is it just
going to keep killing me should i leave
and come back and it's it's interesting
to like go through that everywhere that
you go
yeah it's it's also an elaboration of a
lot of what they have always done right
like we talk about how this game is
basically them extrapolating the core
design principles in an open world and
that feeling of free form exploration
um it's not um
you know uh weird or new to them they do
that all the time it happens within the
first moment of dark souls for most
players they wake up in firing shrine
they go forward take a left and then
they get caught in the skeleton
graveyard and realize
and they try and fight their way through
it and realize [ __ ] i can't do this then
they go to the right and end up you know
an uh undead burg or whatever it may be
um and then come back later and that's
how this game is meant to be placed the
same with most other of their games it's
like you walk in one direction get
knocked on your ass walk in the other
direction and feel like oh i can do that
it's the same in um the the um the
painting system in uh or the archstone
system in demon cells their first game
of this iteration you did one one one
two one three and then realized oh i
can't do one four yeah so i gotta go to
three one three two then like it was
that kind of non-linear progress is so
key to their games i think the thing
that is going to really catch people off
guard is when you put that non-linear
progress in a
open world it can be very overwhelming
and you start to forget that it's
non-linear progress you just feel like
you're being
viciously oppressed by everything
so it's like depending on where you are
yeah yeah exactly i mean
i feel like really makes up for that
like if you couldn't fast travel that
would probably
be annoying but because you can be like
all right i'm out it's not really a
problem and that's such a lovely kind of
quality of life and i wouldn't expect
from software to put into their game
um also the mount
yeah
torrent yeah the the mount is fantastic
what a great way to kind of get in and
out of danger there have been a lot of
these field bosses uh because you're
gonna encounter three different bosses
in this game you're gonna encounter
bosses that are inside of these mini
dungeons the tunnels the caves and so on
and so forth the field bosses will just
be these random things that are out
there and maybe you don't even see them
maybe they just kind of appear out of
nowhere but suddenly you get that big
ass health bar on the bottom you're like
[ __ ] i'm not ready for this i have a lot
of runes right now i'm not prepared to
lose i don't even know what this thing's
gonna bring to the table so you just
peace out you're on your horse and it's
great um
but the i i wasn't expecting them to
have as good and as friendly
player-friendly of a fast travel system
as they do yeah and shout out to them
you don't have to be
at a bonfire or a site of grace or
whatever you could just be anywhere and
teleport to any one of them would unless
you're underground
oh yeah occasionally yeah there's some
areas that you can't bounce but it's not
frequent no not at all not at all um
which is great because like i i don't
know why in this game i just
i don't expect from software to do many
player friendly things
i mean let's not forget that fast travel
wasn't in dark souls 1 until you got to
anor londo which is like most of the way
through that game yeah what
yeah it has to have been something that
they weighed up with play testing i
would think where it
the open world would be infuriating
without it i think it keeps it exciting
you test something out you try to
approach the castle and you get your
butt kicked immediately and you're like
okay try something else and like i feel
like that it's
it's very rewarding and you're always
going to want to go back you know i'd
like to imagine
i'd love to imagine the
all the desert from soft being like
just give them this one
let them have this one because like i
once
one addition is that pouch system um
which is not explicitly sort of
hey use this this will help you out
quite a bit questions because i haven't
looked back at my footage i'm going to
keep this as vague as possible spoil the
free
do you get the pouch
from killing somebody
no it's just there always i wondered if
i had got it as a reward or no it's just
part of it it's just a it's like a pair
of those cargo pens you know you've got
you've got an extra pocket behind it
just got ready
reach down the pouch is such a nice
little system that i wouldn't have
expected to be in there because it's
something that i didn't mean really look
at or give a second thought whenever you
hit start your left side has all those
uh menu items and your top right has
this pouch and it's essentially a weapon
wheel
and i
for a while i kept feeling those
frustrations of like no don't drink the
flask get off the horse like i i was
struggling with a lot of those little
moments uh bringing up the wrong thing
so now i just i set the horse command to
one of the
pouch buttons square up that's mine and
then i set uh two of my most used
spirits to left and down that's a really
good idea and so my down button whenever
i'm in the world is only my heels it's
only my flask or it's only my i still
have everything down
my face you guys uh you guys are crazy i
changed it to bloodborne buttons
immediately triangle is my my heel
button like that
no no but i mean switching down
switching
yeah down on the d-pad to switch between
those items
i think yeah yeah that is default no but
i think tam was thinking that i was
talking about pushing down to heal i was
like that's insane no because in sekiro
it's up to heal yeah unless you change
it around yeah yeah so related to that
we've spoken about how it compares to
breath of the wild again inevitable um
how do you guys feel as very big from
soft fans about how it is going to be
compared to other fromsoft games
i think in the uh also before we move on
i just had the image of when any talked
about them saying let them have one i've
just got this image of someone out from
software just like holding up a video of
a twitch streamer crying and then also
holding up a a a paper that just says
stakes of america on it
yeah yeah you're like
i don't know checkpoints
but i think
i think like if i place this in the
lineage of these souls games like and
and i think that that's where it belongs
it feels like an evolution of dark souls
3 i think it's the best of the bunch
quite quite easily i still i wouldn't
say it's my favorite of those from soft
games like bloodborne is still number
one for me um but i think it stands out
very very favorably and it also thinks
it stan thinks i think it stands apart
from them in a very meaningful way like
this is more ambitious than anything
they've ever done before and it although
it shares the dna of a lot of their own
other games it also feels very very
distinct like super super simple games
ever made again i can't believe how many
things are in the [ __ ] open world
it's it's wild but like there's the
thing the only thing that i'm really
missing from it is a kind of
i don't know a unique twist to combat if
you get what i mean like it it's very
very much dark souls it's dark souls
combat it's dark souls 3 combat in a lot
of ways and then it's got the like
counter system that is is new but kind
of feels a bit like it's the blood-borne
visceral attack thing but just without
the gunshot um and it's nowhere close to
like being as distinct as you know the
front foot combat of bloodborne or the
uh kind of counter system from sakura
yeah i would have loved to have
something like that but i also
understand that for it to accommodate so
many different class types it can't be
like that
and play styles you can't have like that
kind of overriding combat system and
then also have a game where you can be a
mage because it's like yeah yeah majors
aren't countering nothing i do feel like
it is sort of dark souls
colon elden ring but not in a way that's
like
derivative yes they're originally
comments so people were saying it was
like derivative like it's so it's just
dark souls it's not it really is its own
thing but it yeah if you're if you're
familiar with dark souls i think you'll
be very familiar with this
um
andy how do you feel about it how would
you place it in the the from stuff
lineup
um i
i think adding
the open world is that x factor like i i
i think if it were just a linear game we
would say yeah this is pretty much just
another dark souls game with a different
set in a different world about a
different this time you're not
collecting souls you're collecting runes
and things of that nature i think the x
factor is this is that open world and it
just somehow keeps on getting larger and
i cannot believe yeah have either of you
uncovered the whole amount
i i have done so much in this game and
i swear to christ the top right quarter
yeah
completely grayed out and it just gets
it gets bigger like i can't
when when tam and i were doing uh just
sending each other photos back and forth
of our map and suddenly he was like oh
by the way i unlocked this thing
and the map is no longer like 16 by nine
ratio it got taller and i was like oh
we're not finishing this game and it's
only continued to do that there it just
gets on more and more big um
but comparing it to the other souls
games like i think a lot of people's the
number one question is like
hey i didn't like i didn't vibe with
sakura but i love dark souls games will
this be for me or vice versa it's always
a combination of either of those
sakura
um i mean what i was the same way when i
first started off secure i was like nope
this combat ain't for me and um
to a certain extent
i love how the story and the lore is a
bit easier to digest in this game not
that it's by any
i i think so in the way that
it starts to get very
shocker it starts to get very game of
thronesy with the factions
at play or when i was playing the souls
games i just felt like i didn't really
have any context for what was happening
um
and probably just not far enough to have
seen that yet i do feel like i'm
i'm understanding who characters are
potentially a little bit better than in
previous games and
i keep wanting to give you guys examples
but i don't want to spoil anything no
yeah characters i really love that i was
happy to talk to and
well yeah when i when i
find myself explaining this when i say
that
the game does a better job with co-op
by no means is it on the level of any
other co-op game
uh in terms of ease of use when i'd say
that this game is easier to understand
by no means is it
as easy to understand it's like a
naughty dog game yes in comparison to
itself in comparison to usual from soft
games i've i've gotten to the point
where
uh tam and i were actually damning about
a character last night like did you join
up with this character what did they say
and then i ended up going to a new spot
and they mentioned hey join up with us
like [ __ ] this and that and it's like
ooh like this is getting really spicy
there's a lot of like like
uh politics stuff happening a lot of
sub-tweets happening
yeah
dude it's really it's
from private accounts you tell them
it's really cool in a way that i don't
feel like i ever experienced with a
whole lot of the other souls games and
i'm sure i'll be told wrong because
people will say well at cainhurst castle
they talk [ __ ] about blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah you have just a
40-minute youtube video to get that
information
it feels it feels a little bit more on
the surface
which i really appreciate yeah um but in
terms of that like i think gameplay is
is still as solid as ever i am such a
sword and shield guy whenever i play
these souls games i
feel a lot safer i like turning corners
and knowing that i'm going to have my
shield up in case anything is going to
try to catch me off guard
um i am loving all of the variety and
combat arts uh or the the ashes of war
whatever they're called here
they look they they look so cool like
not only just the melee ones where maybe
you sweep or maybe you have a dash uh
cool animation also when somebody else
uses them on you
all of them you can do that oh my gosh
there was a
tom told me about it or tom tam told me
about an npc
that popped up only at night he was like
go this go here and they'll be
one of these characters there'll be a be
a bad guy there at night i was like oh i
gotta go check that out and they had the
coolest [ __ ] ash award i've ever seen
i was like dude you look dope like i
want to see more of this
i was the same i was like dude you look
dope person
a night person that only showed up at
night time but i don't know how many
there are did it did he have a
telekinetic blade
no
yeah exactly he came out and i was like
dude you look sick please stop hating me
yeah that's so bad oh my god i feel like
a cool thing about it is um again trying
to avoid spoilers some of the stuff that
i've
seen cool looking enemies use on me i
then realize is something i can get yeah
i just don't know when
and so now when i see people pull out
cool move sets or like some kind of like
arcane ability i'm like oh my god i just
gotta get my face up and i'll know you
said [ __ ] yeah it's super exciting
because yeah that sense of discovery i
feel like they just nail it from top to
bottom it's so satisfying the fluidity
between changing uh maybe what class
you're trying to be and just knowing
that i can eventually level this thing
up enough and just because i started off
as a warrior i can
i can get the things i need to become a
mage like all that stuff i think makes
it a bit easier and a bit
a bit less constraining
and he knows my struggle to find a good
weapon i think oh my god i i started a
dexterity build and somehow got like a
very powerful rapier and then i was like
i [ __ ] hate the rapier because it's
like it's literally so short that i feel
like i'm trying to poke bosses in the
eye with my fingers and i was like andy
you've got to tell me whether it's a
great sword that you you must have a
grey sword somewhere i've been texting
every time i found a graveyard yeah
it is i i've got one now i've got a
couple but i didn't have a lot of decks
to start with so i couldn't use anything
that was ranged
and yeah in a ton of areas was causing
me problems because i didn't have the
decks to do it but then also when i'm
leveling up early game i'm like strength
strength strength stress and like i'm
not going for the deck something but we
use for crossbow so i i went into decks
and then realized that i needed i wanted
to do the guts from berserk build and i
was like i gotta change this and luckily
found a way to respec
another
founder respect i've got an amazing
dexterity-based blade that i'm like oh
for [ __ ] sake
but you do have to make those choices
for sure yeah yeah and i appreciate that
too like i'm just constantly thinking
about everything but yeah andy how did
you do would you agree with tam that
it's the most like dark souls 3 because
i definitely would agree with that
dark souls 3 is a game that i have only
played about 10 minutes of
so yes
so yes excellent it is very similar it's
a game that i've kept on trying to to
save because i know that
uh i know that the
community that i have built really
really a lot of the kind of funny fans
and people that watch my streams really
want to watch me play it people think
about that and he loves blue ball in
people i don't want i don't want to blow
my souls load in six months and play all
of them and then just be like no more
souls games but i'm hanging yeah exactly
it's like yeah absolutely i don't want
to do it all at once i want you all to
keep coming back right keep going
basically a titty streamer yeah exactly
exactly you know it you know exactly one
day he's gonna be like it's gonna be
like dark souls 3 stream and he's going
to be in a hot tub
i generally agree it is most like dark
souls 3 and again
i'm in agreement that i maybe would have
liked the combat to feel a little bit
less similar i'm not using the um
counter probably as often as i should
because i feel like there are too many
situations where and maybe it's just
like from playing dark souls i've mostly
played dark souls 1 in demon souls um
that i want to roll all the time
there's always like a ball just roll
like
like a period
got it yeah and i just i just don't do
it very often it's also
a bit difficult because
sometimes the timing on every enemy type
is different and there are so many enemy
types that i often will be like should i
just go and try it out oh and i feel
like i'm always slightly too late there
earlier than you think a lot of the time
but because there are so many enemy
types it's really hard to feel like
you're ever going to master it because
you have to figure out the timing for
every different enemy type so i just
can't handle
and the size of the shield uh determines
how quickly the animation happens so if
you have a smaller shield
you can get you can do that [ __ ] really
really fast i've been going sort of the
medium type shield builds and
it it feels significantly tougher to
perry in this game than it did in dark
souls one um
when it comes to just
i i it's very situational for me
whenever i play this game um a lot of
times i am rolling as well
especially when i know that it's a big
boss that my shield isn't gonna do [ __ ]
against let me just two hand this weapon
and get more damage that way it's magic
and your shield doesn't have any magic
exactly exactly um but for the most part
if it's a sort of
humanoid type character i will try to
read what the animations are and
there are a lot of moments where it's
like
man
i don't know if i'm good enough
this quickly to roll past all of your
moves i'm hoping to get lucky with a
couple of these parries yeah so that i
can get that max critical damage um and
plus
oh my gosh adding the
the talisman to give me more health back
to give me health back when i get a
successful critical parry or a back stab
yeah love it i found another talisman
that gives me magic back whenever i do a
critical thing as well so i'm getting
both uh magic and health back whenever i
do a backstabber running out of fp you
you need to you need to send me the
location of that again because i forgot
it and i did that absolutely absolutely
and uh and i also wanted to mention or i
wanted to ask you all what you all think
of the the spirits and are you using
these spirits that you find in the game
yeah so i have a set of spirits that
i've leveled up once and i can't
remember where i got them they're like
these you know those little lads with
the big poles that throw bombs
yeah i got three of those and they are
menaces like if you get them in a boss
fight they are so aggressive that i can
just like sit back when i want to want
to heal and like comfortably know that
whatever the boss is not getting
anywhere near me because they like
they harass people so badly and like i
can get behind them as well and just do
like really uh
repeater charged attacks and do massive
critical strikes so i love those lads um
they survive a while yeah the spirits
are great i like them also because like
sometimes you feel like
you're in trouble and you're like it's
spirit time
the one downside with boss fights though
is that i sometimes can't tell if the
boss is trying to attack my spirits on
me i don't think it's not me and then
get hit
uh but that's my own fault that's not
the game's fault but i'm just like oh i
thought that you were gone for the
spirit
you were looking at them and then you
suddenly like targeted me or whatever
yeah but it's so satisfying uh there was
in like the first few hours of gameplay
um
my character had died and the spirit
took the boss down after i was dead
like even though it obviously didn't
save i was like yeah
you did it
you did it very satisfying to watch
you're getting a promotion yeah look at
you go buddy yeah it's just it's like
having a friend whereas i have not found
many of the uh like summons to be
terribly useful um so far they tend to
just die i was like i found like i found
them like a lot more useful in in demon
souls it's obviously the most recent one
that i played i've never done one summon
it was blind the wolf boy and it was
[ __ ] awesome because he rolled up and
he was like
i'm gonna take care of this pulled out
his giant sword and just started laying
waste to everyone it's incredible i
wasn't able to get that because i had
already beat that boss yeah it's part of
a quest line yeah it's kind of
um so look for the look for the forest i
think it's called miss wood first and
you'll find
a howling wolf
man
and then that's that's all i say i'll
say let's see if you can figure out the
rest of it but if you it's very tricky
to figure out so if you do give up just
let me know and i'll send you the
um solution
the uh
i love the spirits and it's kind of
weird because for a lot of my soul's
experiences
i i don't want help i don't want the
magic build because it feels cheap i
want to suffer i want this game i want
to beat this game the way i feel like i
would be most proud of myself
in this game i'm very much the opposite
i like i never asked
i never got co-op help i never like
summoned npcs in any other games
um in this game for whatever reason i
feel like maybe it's just maybe it's the
tone of
this sort of fantasy setting
that i love having these spirits it
feels like i'm playing world of warcraft
again with my hunter build and i i
summon these these wolves every time
i've leveled them up like five times
already
yeah they are there and and i've
unlocked [ __ ] like 20 maybe by now uh
spirits
i still love the wolves i i love how
aggressive they are and
another good one that i use is the
jellyfish the jellyfish is a [ __ ]
tank
the jellyfish takes poison yeah and it
it just kind of doesn't do a lot
offensive but offensively but it'll get
its attention and it takes hits like a
[ __ ] yeah the wolves um pretty
they go down really quickly yeah yeah
the variables are
the wolves uh again it's all situational
for me if i know how the boss attacks
it's like oh i'm gonna switch to the
jellyfish you do this one move and the
the wolves go out really really quickly
so i'll switch to the jellyfish who is a
lot tougher to take down um and yeah i'm
having a blast with with all the spirits
really and just the concept of it the
npc's however i love
entering a boss fight spawning that npc
for him to help and as he's about to die
bust out my
summons and then kind of like tag team
about you might be feeling that way
because the open world is so big
that you you just come across so many
more
things that want to kill you all the
time that whenever you get to talk to a
person you've had to narrow it down to
exactly where they are in this huge
area
that every time that you do it it is
like this sense of companionship which
is very cheesy but i i feel like i feel
that also that's what i'm saying with
like the summons is sorry the spirits
it's like i'm like oh my friends yeah
yeah yeah
it's also possible that maybe i don't
you know this isn't a a 25 hour linear
experience this is i don't maybe i just
don't want to get stuck on an enemy for
four hours knowing that
there's still 70 more hours of this kind
of world to explore so maybe that's part
of it as well but i'm having a blast
with a lot of what the combats have uh
offered and i played some co-op with our
friend snow bike tonight asked how is
the clock i haven't touched it at all um
the co-op is as
tedious and weird as a from soft co-op
game would be i know i know they said
they made it easier this time around i
don't have a whole lot of experience
with the past co-op experiences but
um the way it works is
if tam wants to summon me to his world
i
have an item
that i put down
and then he uses an item
to be able to see my marking on the
ground
and then can summon me in finger
the finger yeah yes it's very similar to
the other way yeah
the the unfortunate thing about it
though is that this is a big open world
and you go rome and you have fun you
can't use your horses either which
really sucks um
you have you have to just be on on foot
with your friends unfortunately you
can't summon your horses and the thing
that sucks about it is
if we both spawn in at location a
and we run a [ __ ] load of players
beating that bunch of enemies and we go
to location b
i have to leave his world
put down a marking
he has to summon me and when he summons
me i don't
spawn or when i leave his world i spawn
back at location a way the hell back
there
and i have to run back to where he's at
put down my marking and then he can
summon me there so it kind of
we found ourselves just
solo running through the world together
kind of like
in our own worlds and then i would put
down my spot wherever
um you know wherever we end up going and
i think that another annoyance about it
is
i have to leave his world before he
enters a cave
and then
i have to enter the cave on my side
and then i have to put down a marking
like it just kind of becomes this sort
of tedious thing basically like if you
if you want to
co-op the in the open world you're fine
but the moment you try to enter like a
enclosed area you need to basically
re-up your
um kind of connection between each other
so it's taking you out of it's treating
them like multiple open worlds
and in the open world whenever you do
spawn just in somebody's open world it
will kind of
bring up a prompt that says help take
down the area's field boss with your
friend or whatever the hell and so it
assumes that you're just doing that to
take down a field boss when really you
might just want to [ __ ] around and run
around everywhere in the world um so
it's not designed to play the whole game
co-op essentially which is basically
like task rabbit dark souls
exactly exactly um
the the neat thing though is if you do
take down a boss um i obviously don't
get that loot i don't get what that boss
dropped but i get a rune arc and the
rune arcs are really cool because they
help power up
the things that you eventually get later
on in the game um and they're kind of
rare to come by so if you take down
bosses in your friends world you get a
runer oh so you get a good reward for it
i don't i don't know yeah they are super
red to come by but yesterday i went to a
room with five rats and they all had a
run arc on them and i was like dude the
[ __ ] yeah me too
why are you random rats got this [ __ ] on
you yeah and then uh um
one neat thing is like if you kill a
bunch of [ __ ] in that world you get a
bunch of souls if both of you die you
don't lose those souls as the person
that entered the world
you get to keep them you don't have to
go back and go collect them or whatever
you just keep calling them souls i can't
help you yeah same here
oh my souls
it's impossible not to um so in a way go
ahead i was gonna tell you another meme
it's fine keep going i was gonna say in
a way you can kind of double dip because
if you if i help alana through her boss
and we kill her boss i get a [ __ ] load
of souls for that
and then if we want to kill the boss in
my world
i have all the souls that we got for
that reward and then we can go fight him
again and double up on it in a way and i
i found we found ourselves leveling up
pretty quickly because of it so there
aren't it isn't all bad it's just
i fear that this is going to be a lot of
people's first souls game uh because
they
see the hype around it and maybe you
want to try out this big open world game
and they're going to go why is co-op
this way yeah why can't i just join your
server it's like
this is just the way trump's off this is
yeah which is like which is kind of bad
um yeah it's pretty janky but but
totally yeah i
i would not have expected any
differently um yeah but related to that
uh the most common question that i've
seen is is people who've never played
from soft games before asking if they
will be able to play this one and or if
they think that this is a good place to
start i still think this game is very
hard um it's not it's not any easier the
only thing that makes it easier
is you can technically grind in a
different way um
well it's more that you can run away
from things if they're too hot and then
you can go to an easier area and you can
try again and it's not like you can't do
that in the previous games it's just i
feel like when it's in an open world and
you're not stuck with the room that's
right in front of you it just feels a
little bit easier but i don't actually
think the difficulty has been decreased
at all
yeah the way i say is like if you have
bounced off previous souls games and you
really know that they haven't been for
you this isn't going to be the one that
somebody turns it around for you like
it's it's very obtuse in in a lot of
ways and it also kind of relies on a lot
of assumed knowledge or that you should
you would only have through accumulating
it and playing
still very like yeah better have played
this before it assumes that you know the
things about
certain concepts and doesn't really
spend a lot of time reinforcing it in
the way that modern games do where they
tell you it three times and in different
contexts so that you are absolutely no
it never tells you what the scaling does
it never tells you like you know x y and
z mechanic how this works it's like very
much like you know world tendency back
in the day or it's like it's there if
you want to figure it out good luck if
you don't this might ruin your life
enjoy it oh and and shout out to them
for at least pointing out when you have
a light medium or heavy load oh i know
i was like they do that now shout out to
that
i don't know if dark souls 3 did that
but nope um that was always number based
before that was always a pain in the ass
and just having to go back and be like
oh no that's still a fat roll okay
what's the percentage well i didn't wait
oh it's not just 75 total it's 75 of
what i have just says like in the middle
and i can't do math it just says medium
and i'm like
oh my god it's awesome i am a medium
thank you
how did you know
i will say though the question i've been
getting
you know will this be could this be my
first from soft game the question i've
been getting that the most
from our people that
aren't
that haven't bounced off from prior
versions
yeah they just haven't tried because
they've been maybe too worried or been
too kind of you know put off by the all
the the hype around the difficulty and
things of that nature i do think that
the addition of these spirits makes
things make these boss fights definitely
way more manageable however i found
myself
uh getting a little too comfortable with
these spirits
um
and you know
one thing leads to another
no uh i i would find myself in areas
where you can't spawn the spirits being
like oh [ __ ] i gotta like i gotta like
fight well here and i i think i'm pretty
decent at these games but there's
moments where
random [ __ ] night on the way to the
main boss is whooping my ass it's like
[ __ ] leave me alone dude go away yeah
sometimes you go find like a random
enemy who's like looking to get a
promotion or impress a friend and you're
like you [ __ ] jobs worth like i hate
you so much
yeah
no i love that though too because again
it's always surprising uh big fan i i
feel like i don't know if the hardcore
souls community gets angry about this
suggestion but um i've always said that
i recommend that you play
fromsoft games probably except
bloodborne funnily enough with a guide
i'm not saying that you read the guide
every step of the way but you are
willing to allow yourself to look at the
guide if you need help because like
i love sakura i would recommend sakura
to everybody even people who don't like
hard games so you just have to figure it
out
but there are areas where it's like you
need to talk to this person three times
and then this npc will spawn in this
area and then they'll spawn in this area
and then you get this item from this
person in this order
that's so off-putting to so many people
uh especially compared to you know most
games that they will have played that
i'm like don't feel bad about having a
guide while you play this
there's a there's there's this thing
called the the cheat sheets that a lot
of people have been made like on github
and stuff and it's basically like a list
of things that will help you do main
comp like mostly completion and it's
literally like a checklist so for dark
souls doesn't really spoil anything no
so like i'm looking at the dark souls
one now and it's like it's got check
boxes next to it and it's just like grab
dungeon cell key run past asylum demon
grab your sword and shield remember
about the boulder talk to asylum night
and get the esses flask and you just
take it off one by one as you go through
it it tells you what to do but it's
still on you to mechanically do it and
it's really fun and like if you follow
it like point by point you'll not only
be guided but by time you're done you'll
have all the achievements and have done
everything possible and seen all the
quests but it doesn't like spoil how to
beat bosses no it won't be like hey do
this this and this it will just be like
be this boss you know go here attacks
it's really cool yeah that's perfect
yeah they're great yeah i recommend
people give that kind of thing a try um
if you want to start for the first time
obviously if you've got a little bit
more experience you probably don't need
to but otherwise yeah it can be
difficult to to get in because they're
difficult in more ways than just combat
like
they are like we said items can be
really confusing and they are absolutely
still that way in elden ring they don't
suddenly make more sense
there's still stuff that you'll just say
i don't [ __ ] know what it does and i
can't wait to find out
um talisman's rule the talismans are
great the flask of wondrous physic rules
oh god yeah
recipes i got pretty into recipes
actually i've got some really cool
upgrades for that physic thing that
you know this this one upgrade that i
found after killing a random boss
uh gradually will gain health for me and
the other one that i added in is like
either a better stamina region or an
attack boost like all of that stuff just
it just makes me feel stronger and more
prepared for these fights and just
really dig the vibe it puts out
it's a good ass video game yeah um my
final question for you both if i remove
the ability for you to talk about the
open world what is your favorite thing
about it what do you think is the best
thing about it you can't say the open
world level design
oh i imagine that's what all the reviews
are going to say i'm actually excited to
read them all together i might my
favorite my favorite moment so far has
been not an open world it's some it's a
straight up 10 nope moment that i had
which was like andy knows exactly the
one it's the lift um where like i was
and this is partly because we were
playing on deadline and i was trying to
get it completed but like there's a
moment where you step on a lift and the
lift goes down and then it goes down and
then it goes down and it keeps going
down and it keeps going down and then it
goes down a little bit more and just
when you think you're there it goes down
a bit more and then it comes out at the
bottom and you're like
jesus
christ there is a whole other game
underneath this game and then like when
that happened i like saw it i touched
the uh sight of grace and i was like
i'll come back here another time i just
left and i was like i cannot believe
that that exists in just a corner of
this world and i'm 100 sure that that's
just one of many things like that that
counts as open world tam
yeah i mean like but the area down there
is like very enclosed it's like a
classic dark souls area or like a from
soft area but it's
massive from what you think you haven't
gone through yeah yeah i was able to go
through all of it um i'm kind of saving
that i mean it's kind of related to what
tam is saying but it's those it's those
surprises it's um
i think that's my favorite thing about
all of their games is the surprises yeah
it's so exciting i mean like i
having those moments and going like god
damn dude this game has not
slowed down in terms of like amazing me
where i'm still this many hours in i'm
still seeing things i haven't seen
before
the level of love and care put into
stuff that
who knows if anybody's ever gonna see or
hear that npc but it's there
and it's all of those moments that just
really impressed me um
because
they didn't have to go that hard for an
area that you may not even
be able to go into because of whatever
but the fact that it's still there the
fact that it happens like it all those
little things uh really blow me away i'd
say the day night cycle as well all the
conditional stuff whenever things happen
under the
certain conditions um the nighttime
bosses are
are just always a surprise to me when
they do happen and it's it's so badass
i'm going to say mine is um it's really
[ __ ] pretty
like yeah like just in a way that their
games usually aren't um
yeah and i never got bored of seeing
those like rays in the sky and the giant
trees
um and even in the areas that are ugly
they're really colorful like
dark souls 2 has that kind of bland
palette that it seems like it's really
easy to to lean back on there like i
mean plenty of areas that all the souls
games have just like kind of like gray
greeny sort of hue
um this has areas that are swamps and
they're [ __ ] pink it's just really
like colorful pretty like consistently
interesting to look at even just yeah
the the art design and the way the world
is laid out is just i was just like
constantly like damn you're so cool
you get them gold flakes written down on
you yeah
really cool i also
just like again i keep talking about
enemy variety but it's also enemy
placement like there's
areas where i was like i want to check
out whatever that fort is so i'm going
to walk towards that and then i get
closer and then there's this weird
[ __ ] thing on a tree and then there's
another thing but it's not the same as
that thing on a tree and then there are
four of them on the ground and then i'm
like this one looks like a shih tzu like
it's so wild and there's there's so many
of them and all you needed to do was
show me the fort and i would have been
like oh just walk for a full minute but
then i have to figure out where i'm
going to walk because all this weird
[ __ ] in the area and then there's a
[ __ ] tower and i'm like what's in the
tower like it's and it's so close
together i'm just like i'm legitimately
amazed by the amount of stuff that's in
this open world
there there are a couple of fours with
really cool uh
mystery type
treasure hunt things that happen where
sometimes you may get a map sometimes
you may not uh but in in this case kind
of
walking up to a floating glyph and being
like what the hell is this and there's
two stats there's a statue next to it
and you read the book and it's like
find the other floating glibs it's like
oh this is cool yeah there's a there's
puzzles
just go look around for that [ __ ] cool
passive exploration it's not people
trying to kill you yeah and i know that
some people's uh issues with it was like
well the only way you interact with this
game is by hacking
something at something it's like well
i mean true but
i mean it's still rules
like i i enjoy all that stuff i i really
enjoy the platforming i know that
people that's platforming yeah
i love platforming and games and i love
when platforming in games
um when there's a lot of risk involved
and this game has that in spades the
tension of jumping from one platform to
the other landing and then watching your
character just
of their own relation take one more step
forward and be like no
you're like oh why'd he do that
yeah it's
it's a special it's an experience um
andy would you say that it's your
favorite
from soft game if tams is bloodborne and
mine sakura is i'd say mine is still
bloodborne but because that the the
story there i think just connected with
me i mean well bloodborne i just really
love the parry system
you're ranking like you know tens um at
this point yeah um for me it was it was
just mostly kind of uncovering all the
lore that that happens there i think
like dark souls one is probably my
number two and that's like the level
design wowed me so much that it vaulted
up way up there even though the story
i'm not really you know
thinking about you know what that what
happened in dark souls won a whole lot
like the lore of jonathan is especially
like yeah yeah
it is very cool and plus it's also just
fun and the combat's great and there's a
lot of cool bosses um it's called
it so
can't forget that
um well thank you guys for joining me i
feel like we could talk about this
forever and i want to like i just want
to talk to people about it for the next
week all the time there's a lot more
that we could say
um but mostly i hope people have fun
uh
accessibility sucks dude does it yeah
there's nothing there there's just
nothing there that's terrible and
unfortunate which is not shocking yeah
yeah unfortunately we brought that up in
our review as well yeah
yeah i had not looked at the menu uh
which obviously i should but yeah that's
that's a huge bummer um
uh tam where can people find you
you can find my work on gamespot.com my
old ring review is there i'm also with
uh andy talking to um blessing and tim
about on kind of funny and then ice
tweets tweem i stream on twitch
many times a week uh monday wednesdays
and fridays i'm probably gonna stream
out of the ring um i've been off for a
bit because i've been working on the
review and i just did not have any time
but yeah that's pretty much it yeah and
i'm on twitter out to my age
how about you andy
kind of funny games twitch and youtube
and i
and tick tock and i am the andy cortez
on pretty much everywhere twitter
instagram leave links in the description
to where you can find them to everybody
watching thank you both for joining me
see you guys next time